theme review meme review me and review
welcome to another episode of meme
review the most beloved show on YouTube
YouTube put this last one on trending
which means where I'm doing something
right that was a lie I don't know why I
lied about that at him let's have a
quick look from last week meme review
what were the memes we discussed the
bike cut meme which we saw some
different irradiation stuff which was
nice to see we also have Fenton o
posting my content got stolen recently
meme review stolen bike me I was pretty
bummed out about it but I think whoever
stole it was probably more happy to get
it didn't I'm sad to lose it so whatever
what is he talking about I did not steal
meme review from anyone okay name review
is an original I did
now the first meme that we're gonna
review for this week's meme review is
arguably the greatest meme of all time
this is the kind of mean that sets our
civilization apart and elevates it to
another level
this is humankind taking its next foot
into the future I'm talking of course
about petting dog mean petting dog meme
must be the greatest me of all time
basically you have anyone doing anything
oh look I'm dog meaning right now that's
how easy it is and just replace their
arms with a petting a dog how does this
mean work out that the thing about this
meme it's that it has many layers it has
many layers of adaptability almost
anything can transform in petting dog
mean her he's probably thinking about
other girls him getting done you even
have cats petting dogs isn't that insane
Cory in the house
now that's a little dink you know it has
a lot of bit of bank nough Stu it
because clearly Cory is black and the
hand that's petting the dogs
if white that is not allowed that is
cultural appropriating but of course
there's some innocence once and I think
the floor nests in the mean it's what
makes it funny here with that josh is a
Drake or Josh I don't remember here with
Josh's hand looking completely deformed
we have stranger things with the dog
meme I'm surprised I didn't go for all
the tentacles they they decided to
simplify the meme to a single tentacle
of padding dog mean isn't this meme just
the greatest my personal favorite with
the petting dog meme is the fact that
you can take anything that might seem as
bad you know anything any form of hand
gestures that can be seen as a negative
hand gesture can be saved through
petting dog mean here you have me for
example you have a Caesar doing the
thumbs
I made this me myself I'm quite proud
the original this meme started on the me
in real life forum which I found out
people aren't people aren't too fun of
this by the me in RL but it started off
with this tweet as well getting a lot of
attention I think it was first
documented around November 15 so it's a
it's just so much fresh meme some would
say now this isn't really that funny
maybe it's the skill acquired in it to
pet this dog the way he goes out of his
way to pet the dog that is funny about
it but you know there are some very dank
options for this of course there's
always you know other ends of each
spectrum it's also very layered mean of
course there's there's the petting dog
meme petting dog mean I'm surprised I
didn't go further to be honest then we
also have I don't really know yeah as
you can see it works for anyone it
transcends humans it doesn't just have
to be humans and like I said anything
bad not that there's anything wrong with
this image can turn into something good
I made this one as well so I've seen the
original it also it's a very compatible
meme it combines with many other memes
as you can see here the petting dog meme
really transcends our Universal being
it's the Pythagoras I was the cold
potato triangle Pythagorean theorem you
know how philosophically the triangle
the mathematical equation A to B 2
equals C 2 is a universal like math this
universal anywhere in the universe
a 2 B 2 C 2 is going to be the same no
matter where in time or wearing universe
that is the law of the universe we are
describing something that is taking
transcends all of our mortal form and
just like that this meme does the exact
same thing so I'm gonna have to go ahead
and rate this meme a solid 5 point 5 out
of 10
all right so weird ugh we're done with
it
dog means so you can go now for the next
meme please four main reviewed next
monkey haircut FC seen here in the
combin in the cut in the crossover meme
we have the monkey haircut mean critics
would say that the dog petting meme was
spawned originally from the monkey sad
so sorry the sad monkey haircut me now
this one is a bit older it's original
seam to be hard to pinpoint but it
started with this viral video of a cute
little monkey getting a haircut but it's
sad it's not happy about haircut monkey
is not - please - but why are you giving
a monkey a haircut but it was the monkey
haircut that started this bad Photoshop
new hands sort of thing here we have
Donald Trump it's actually very good
match Donald Trump giving sad monkey
haircut we got Rambo giving sad monkey
haircut we have Donald Trump in
wrestling giving monkey haircut
we have monkey giving monkey haircut we
have anime girl giving monkey haircut we
have of course the lost generation of
the monkey haircut Gordon Ramsay monkey
haircut big shucks
monkey haircut stolen monkey haircut and
we also have the inception version of it
the monkey haircut given monkey haircut
we also even have a pity pie version of
it which I made myself but I gotta say
there's something about this meme that
just kind of annoys me I don't know why
it just never stops here we have haircut
man getting haircut giving monkey
haircut the biggest crossover of means I
have ever seen we have of course no arms
man Beach person giving monkey haircut
anime whamon haircut Edward Scissorhands
haircut whatever the [ __ ] this is
haircut I think what makes this meme so
popular is because how shittier
the funnier the meme here we have
another one I made and it just becomes
funny I would have to give this meme a
solid 6 it's better than the petting dog
me because the original one is always
better and I'm gonna add that that that
I myself there and gonna have to say
this is I'm giving this a 4.5 nah I'm
gonna have it's a 5 it's a 5 everybody
its global it's easily adaptable its
original I think it could have gotten
some more points actually you know what
it's a 5 point 2 because of its
melancholic depression undertone which I
think will hike Hyden any mean next this
is the meme that we have all been
waiting for this is the meme that I pick
the best one for last and not because I
need this video to be ten minutes it's
December
come on give me that revenue January
it's gonna be dead and I need another
mean I need a banger I need a banger
what did we get yeah now that's it
that's a good name right there well done
so Xenoblade Chronicles 2 recently came
out and one of the characters looks like
truly mind-bending material here with
them with the back looking like she
needs a serious chiropractic visit now
it's not like xenoblade has the best
track record of its proportion people
were quick to point out how Dalia wishes
the name over the character looks like a
Yoshi that grew ahead we immediately
have people making comparison to I think
two other things looking similar to
dahlias character design and from
different anime combinations that
created this atrocity such as dick foot
Captain America perhaps now social
justice warrior were quick to point out
how terrible this is to objectify er
whamon - looks like it's something
goddamn wrong with her
if you ask me this is perfectly fine
human anatomy okay if anything Captain
America has bigger knockers than Dahlia
of course the internet was furious about
this how could how dare they make a
disproportionate women in a fictional
video game disgusting
whenever I'm played now that I'm playing
seen a blade I literally have to close
my eyes I can't even look at it it
offends my very being and it offends my
very core now this is not much of a meme
you might say Felix I what are you what
are you talking about here thank you for
watching name review I'm gonna read the
last Dahlia meme probably a solid two
and A two and a half because it will
probably be dead in a couple days meme
review thank you for watching another
episode of name review what means you
want me to review in the next episode
leave a comment down below because oh
boy do I need help
we're on Episode two and I'm already
grasping for straws is that the
expression I don't squat them out main
review